last one day last one okay good
hello everyone I'm gasps I'm down with a
slow mo guys and we're incredibly on
edge right now
yeah I'm nervous why you nervous well
it's not just because I'm about to jump
into a load of mousetraps it's because I
don't want to go off before I do yeah
this took hours we've spent four hours
doing this we had a couple of calamities
[Applause]
what happened however you did while I
was putting butter but now Dan is ready
to leap from that ladder onto the
trampoline full of I assume like a
thousand Mouse I think there is about a
thousand we've done now someone could
freeze frame and count let's get out the
way all right good luck counting Dan
yeah ready yeah I just want to get on
with it let's go good luck thank you
very much I did offer to do it they
didn't I you did good I would have done
it yeah but I didn't want to mess up the
button trigger I didn't want that
responsibility oh god I don't think
there could possibly be a jankier table
to jump off this is like horrendous
don't try this at home ladies and gents
I'm ready to go into the mousetraps be
okay go for it you ready yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god wait how is that I think they
all went off I think so oh and off
goodness me
wait where do the goggles go I didn't
come on you didn't put the clothes on I
forgot I just saw it close my eyes and
hoped we had him where were they oh they
weren't here oh did that hurt
well I just got like little nips all
over my body oh it wasn't like anything
really painful that she kind of comfy oh
the main thing was falling to the
trampoline to be honest I just keep this
era I think they all went off that one
didn't let me see Shelley see how many
minutes look at that you can tell I gave
it my all
God you always captain video yourself
almost like yeah look at that oh that
was a tremendous performance and I can't
believe you did it without goggles but
yeah I know I just got to you I was just
like I can't do it go at this point
my fate is sealed yeah it's like there's
nothing I can do it was at this point
that he knew oh you're in your hands
you're like going on that all of them in
like states still and then God yo sky
from the outside and went in that's so
cool it look like it like a speaker
current yeah
Oh blowing up in the air now everything
bounces back
that was tremendous being along my legs
are up in the air still now that was
class I look like some sort of
mysterious silhouette man yeah you
haven't unlocked your character yet so I
realized I did the intro wearing a
cowboy hat and I didn't mention the
cowboy hat which means the audience
thinks that I thought I could pull off a
cowboy hat yeah you definitely can't I
know you don't in reality I was just it
was sunny and I was trying to wear a hat
and this is my new favorite hat but this
is my new favourite hospital that's
quite good actually yeah I thought that
footage was tremendous we actually had
the perfect amount of mousetraps to
visualize that sort of inward chain
reaction you would never have guessed
that either no who'd have thought that
because we covered every square inch
with a mousetrap yeah see exactly sort
of the reaction and in real time because
I was so like adrenaline and frantic
about the mall going off by accident
which they did while we were setting
them up yeah I didn't really pay
attention to what order it all happen
didn't even see it okay I think
afterwards you you'd push the button and
then you're panicking so you're like
have we got it because that was the
biggest amount of effort like that was
probably an hour per second of footage
there were four hours to set it up and
we recorded for four seconds yes an hour
per second thankfully our camera can
stretch one second into several minutes
so takes away from having the right
camera yeah oh all right well it's quite
short and sweet but hopefully uh
hopefully you enjoyed it I always like
those just simple ideas they're often my
favorite ones yeah feel free to follow
us on Twitter subscribe to the main
channel we've got a second channel if
you want as well and we will see you in
the next video which is a slightly
special one I hope you trap a good
audience for that trap a good audience a
strap yeah